そこで次にある人が 例えば知恵を開発しようとする
でもなかなかうまくいかない
なかなかうまくいかないのはどういうわけかと
そちらでお釈迦様は説明しています
アナワッティト チッタッサ
心が安定していない チッタ
心 アナワッティタっていうのは不安定な状態で
優柔不断状態で 悩んでいる状態で
心は優柔不断で悩んでいる状態で
安定していない 不安定な状態
不安な状態であるならば
この三十八番目の最後のセクションを見てください
パンニャーナ パリプーラティ
パンニャーというのは知恵
ナ パリプーラティっていうのは完成しない
満たさない 知恵が満たせない
完成しない 誰に？心が不安なら
それでもつなげます 心は不安なら
心は悩んでいるなら 知恵は完成しない
それで知恵は完成するために必要な条件なんですね
しっかりした心 優柔不断な状態はいけない
で すごく難しい状態でもないんです
これは子供たちの例で見るとわかります
例えばクラスに座っている子供たちは落ち着いて座っていないんですね
体ぐにゃぐにゃぐにゃぐにゃしているんです
足を激しく振ったりして
で 左に見たり 右を見たり
右側にいる子供に何か言ったり
それから左側にいる子供にまた何か言ったり
また後ろの子供に何か言ったり
そのまま足で前の机を蹴ったり
前の座っている子供にまた足で蹴ったり何かしたりとか
そういう状態でいる子供がいる
ほとんどそういう状態でしょう
勉強できると思いますかね
黒板を見てくださっても
もう五秒ぐらいでもじっと見ることできない
見ながらあっちこっち見る
黒板を見ると言ったら
カチンとしっかりと見ないと
その映像は頭に焼き付かないんですよ
だから頭が悪いと勉強できないと言うのであって
黒板を見る場合はきちっとピントを合わせて見ちゃうと
黒板に書いたものそのまま頭に映像が記録されます
簡単です 何かのテキストのこと先生説明するときは
まあ意味のないことを喋ってるとこはいいんですけど
ちゃんと授業を始めて
ちゃんと大事なところを言うときちんと聞くと
その音は脳に記録されますよ
だからこちらでも不安定っていうのは
この我々は 例えばこのカップに何か飲み物
水を入れようとする そこで人があの何か持ってきて
自分のカップに水を水を入れようとする
相手が水を注いでます
それでカップを持ってる私がこうしたり
こうしたり こうやったり
こんなことをやっていると水入れられますかね
私は手でカップを持って体ぐるぐる回るわ上下するわ振れ振れたりするわ揺らしたりするわ
そうすると あの人がいくら頑張っても水がこぼれるんであって
あのカップの中に入らない
それで私は文句を言う
水飲みたいんだけど 水を入れてくれと
入れてくれと言うなり手を振ったりする
振ったり カップを回したり
裏返したりしたり いろんなことをしている
逆さまにしたりとかね
それであの人は注ごうと思ったって
まだ水がこぼれる そこでこちらが文句を言う
何やってるんですかと
失礼ではないかと せっかく喉が渇いて水飲みたがっているのに
そんな態度で生きているんだからね
間違えるのは自分でしょうに
喉が渇いているならば
カップをしっかりとつかまる必要
これは自分の責任なんです
そこで相手がはい どうぞと言って冷たい水を入れるかもしれません
これでこの水飲みたくてガラスを持って
相手がもうミネラルウォーターを持っているペットボトルを
じゃあ水ちょっとちょうだいと
喉が渇いたんだと と言ったところまではいいんだけど
我々は手で持っているガラスを回したりする
揺らしたりする 逆さまにしたりする
もう 1秒でも安定して置かない場合は
相手がどうやってあのペットボトルからガラスに水を入れられますかね
その状態だったら 決してその人が喉が渇いたままで水は飲めない
その例を自分に入れてください
我々の心が不安定な状態で揺らいでいて
何一つの瞬間でも集中しない状態でいるならば
何年いても成長はないんですよ
人類はそういうふうに生きているんですよ
そこで ものすごい高度な心理学的なレベルでお釈迦様がもう誰が正しいか
誰が間違っているかというくだらないガキの喧嘩をしてないんです
仏教は 俺の神様が正しくて
あなたの神様が正しくないという
くだらない無意味な喧嘩言ってるわけじゃないんです
で そんなゴミの世界を置いといて
まず人間が心を安定する
聞くときは真面目に聞く
見るときは真面目に見る
見たものは意味がないんだったら忘れちゃえばいいし
意味があるものだったら覚えておけばいいんです
だから学校やら塾に行っても頭がよくなってないという場合は
いきなり学校に文句言う
塾に文句言うでしょうに
それまた自慢もするでしょうに
学校なんか聞いたところで
先生たちがこの PTA の人々には随分おびえているみたい
親たちに そういう理屈でいるんです
自分の子供が勉強しないんだったら
それは学校が悪い 勉強するのは子供ということはもう考えることもしない
教えるのはあなたではないかと言って向こうに文句を言うんです
あなたの子供はあまり
もうお子さんはあまり真面目に勉強しないんですよったら
もうその先生はもうどうなるかわからない
もしかするともう暗殺されるかもしれません道路で
その親に うちのことに悪口言ったと
[背景音楽]それぐらい無知のレベルがもうかなり強烈です
で だからそういう生き方やめてほしいんですよ
学校に行って勉強しないんだったら
もう 2つ先生は真面目に教えているのか
自分の子供は真面目に勉強しているのかで 2つも必要でしょうに
この 2つも必要ですが
私がそれでも言うのはあなたが悪いという状態なんです
自分の弟子たちにも言うのは
あなた方は悪い ただそれだけ
で この先生はもうどこかどこか何か用事がある
用事があると言って そっちを休業にするんだと
私は私にそれ言ったら
だから何を言いたいんですかと
先生がいない時 あんた何やっていたんですかと
先生が来なかった だから遊ぶぞと言ったらそちらが悪いでしょうね
で 世界っていうのはうまくできてあって
例えばある先生が勉強教えないでもうもうもういい加減もうもうサボってサボっている時でも
生徒たちがすごく勉強したいという気持ちになっていると
誰かが教えてあげるんですよ
勉強したいという気持ちさえあれば
世の中は面白いことで誰かが教えてあげる
面白いんですよ 親戚の子供が女の子なんですけど
で ちょっと成績がちょっと悪いと母親に言われて
それは君なんでしょうかね？と言ったら
あの子はガチャガチャガチャガチャガチャガチャもう学校はこんな状態だと
で もう別な学校に入ろうと思いますけど
ものすごい条件厳しくて入れないということで
それは何が悪いんですかと
私はいきなり言ったのはあんた悪いんじゃないのと
別に自分の親戚だからね
それにも反対しなかったんですけどね
何言うんでしょうかとかね
それに何も言わないで
もう学校の状況と先生の状況と言ってね
先生は授業に来ないんだと
なんで来ないんですかと言ったら
何か生徒たちがすごい性格が悪くて
ものすごい汚い言葉で先生怒鳴ったり叱ったり
いろんなことをするんであって
あまりの言葉 汚いんだから先生たちは逃げるんだと
ということで おそらく先生たちも女の人だったと思います
クラスにいる男たちがね
それ聞いたら いくらなんでも
女の子一人には戦えないし
で 私から見ても やっぱりこれは自分の子供
別な学校にするしか方法ないんですよ
でも学校を変えるっていうことはそう簡単じゃないんです
向こうは厳しい もう各学校を入れる条件
自分たちで勝手に決めてやるんだから
もうなかなか大変です
それで私はあの子供に言ったのは
それあんた何言ってもあんた勉強しないで成績が下がったらあんたの負けやと
悪いのはあんただよと
大きくなったところで
今クラスの友達が来て
私のせいで勉強できなかったんだから許してくださいと言わないんだよと
それ覚えておきなさいよと言って帰りましたけどね
やっぱり やっぱり自分が自分の親戚だから
まあもう一応 目になりますけど
やっぱり正しい生き方だけは教えてあげたんです
先生が悪くて クラスの仲間がみんな最悪状態にいても
そうすると子供には勉強できないはずなんですよ
それでも自己責任だと
言っておいたんです そういうことは日本ではそうそうできない
学校は先生が悪いと うちの子はいいということで
それではもう真理の世界じゃないんです
一人一人が独立している生命なんです
我々はこの世の中であの独立して生まれてるんですよ
これ忘れているんです
教えるのはあなたの責任ではないかとかね
そんな約束で生まれるところはなかったんですよ
産んでから母親は嫌やこの子はって捨てたっても母を裏向けんでないんです
どなたか約束あって生まれた人がいますかね
約束して 私はあなたのお腹に生まれますから
あなたは私を育てる 育ててあげるって約束しますか？と
はいはい 私は約束しますから
どうぞ私のお腹に入ってくださいと
そういう約束あったならば大丈夫ですけど
そんなことないですよね
勝手に入って勝手に生まれたのに
それから母に向かってお前のせいやとか言うんだから
しっかりした母親が子供を悪口言う場合はね
お前殺さなかったことで母に感謝しなさいと言うべきところはどうですかね
簡単に殺せたのに 何のことなど
ちゃんと五体満足でもうちゃんと産んでちゃんと育てたでしょうにと
それで十分ですよ 母親の仕事は
だって産んだ子供でも母親がなんか嫌だ
これは育てたくないと思って育てたってもしょうがないんですよ
別に 我々はそんな約束
契約書を書いているわけじゃないんです
保証書をもらって生まれたわけじゃないんです
だからそこからの人間間違ってます
なんで子供が簡単に歩けるところで学校を作ってないんですか？と
なんで子供にはちゃんともう安心して遊びながら学校に通うように通学路を作ってないんでしょうかとかね
あれこれとか 世間に文句ばっかり言う
自分の責任で生まれたと
自分が独立しているんだと
それを忘れているんです
あなたのせい あなたのせい
あなたのせい だから私がダメな人間にはしょうがないという結論に至るんです
それで世界はずっとダメなんです
いい世界になった記録はないんです
これからももっとダメになるんであって
良くなるっていうことはないんです
なぜかというと ずっと人類はそういう間違った思考パターンで生きているんです
それはもう大胆に改革して幸福な世界を作ろうっていうのが仏教の世界なんです
だから大胆さに気づかないんですよ
気づいたらやる気が出てくるんです
だからこちらで言うのは
まず落ち着きなさいよと
落ち着け それぐらいできるでしょうに
人が喋ってるとちょっと聞くというぐらいの
ちょっと落ち着いて聞くだけで頭が良くなりますよ
だからあの人の話が下手
話が下手 あんなこと言う
前にあんた聞いていたんですかと
それでまず落ち着くこと
心の安定 優柔不断状態ないと言ったら
ちょっとあんまりも意味が増えてきますから
そこまで理解しなくていいんです
小さな子供の暮らして考えてください
子供は学校に入れて教室に座らせたんだけど
そいつは座った瞬間からもうぐにゃぐにゃぐにゃぐにゃぐにゃぐにゃ
もう落ち着かないんだったら
もう何か勉強する時予想はできないんです
ちゃんと落ち着いて座っているならば
なんとかうまくいきそうだなということは我々には考えられます
あの子はちゃんと丁寧に座っている
なんとかうまくいきそうだと
そういうことで 知恵の育ち方の 第1 条件は落ち着くこと
覚えておいてください
このグラスと水を入れる例えで
いくら目の前にペットボトル一杯ミネラルウォーターあっても
自分で用意したって 自分がこのガラスを振ったりするともう入ることはないんです
はい 次はサッダンマンアビジャナと
サッダンマンというのは真理ということなんですね
法ということでね お釈迦様おっしゃった教えはサッダルマというんですね
正法 正しい教えというかね
日本では妙法という言葉は人気ありますね
南妙法と言っても呪文となったりするでしょう
妙法というのはパーリ語ではサッダルマという言葉なんですね
だから法に妙な漢字を入れちゃって
だから妙なことばっかりやっています
また脱線なんですね 道とは全く関係ないことをしているんです
だからサッダルマというのは妙法
でも漢字としてはね 珍しい
まれなことで素晴らしいという意味の意味の漢字ですけどね
今の使い方は変ですけど
当時の中国の人々は変な感じ
変な訳したわけじゃないんです
で いわゆる素晴らしい
純粋なクリスタルクリアな素晴らしい教えということで
サッダルマ妙法と言ってるんです
だからいわゆる本物ですね
本当のこと 正しいこと
真理 アビジャナと知らない
アビジャナと言うと それで知ることはできないからという意味になるんです
もう心は落ち着いてないならば
正しい教えは知ることはできないでしょう
できないから 心は落ち着いてないものには正しい真理を理解することができないゆえにという訳になります
だから正しい真理を理解する
理解したい人が心を落ち着くということは必要な条件になります
で さらに詳しい説明をしますが
サッダルマっていうのは真理であって
真理といえば唯一のものなんですよ
真理たくさんないんです
真理に至ったら答え一つになるんです
例えば地球が丸いということは事実ですね
それにはたくさんアイデアがあるわけじゃないんです
もう丸いということはもうもう証明できて
もう結論もできて もう証拠もできて
もう終わってるんです
だから地球の形はいかがでしょうかという質問には
答えたった一つ丸いという
変わらないんです しかしまだ結論に至ってない場合は意見たくさんあります
結論に至ってないところの情報はまだまだ足らない
まだまだ勉強は足らない
だから科学の世界で まあ地球は丸いというぐらいはもうしっかりしています
月と太陽の距離はどれぐらいと言えば
これはしっかりしています
しかし もっと宇宙のことになってくると
何一つしっかりしてないです
全部曖昧中途半端なことばっかりしてるんです
科学者は嘘をついているわけじゃなくて
まあ情報は足らない ある情報で物語を作る
科学者やってはいけないことを物語を作ることなんです
しかし 文化系の人々よりは随分上手に物語を作るんです
文化系の連中も科学者に学べば
もっといい小説やら書けると思いますけど
いかにバレないように嘘をつくかってこと
科学者が上手なんです
まあとにかく科学の世界というのはかなり物語の世界で
あのまあ なんとか何とかデータが通った途端
もうそこで物語を作る
で なんかどこかでちょっとしたデータのミスだと思いますけど
何か水があるんだと もうただのもう伝わってくる電子信号だからね
いくらでもいろいろ問題が起こる可能性あるし
ノイズ入ったりもするし
もうわからない それで水があるに至っても
かなり強烈に熱いところだからね
そこでこれはまあ地下にものすごい大量の水が凍って氷としてあるんだと
ではないかなと思う そこで終わらないんですよ
それからもういろんなイメージ映像を描いて
もうそこでこの開発して開拓して
まあこの何て言いますか
コロニー作ったり もうそうです
もう植物を まあかくかくかくかく
あのちっぽけなデータが正しいかないかどうかもわからない
そこからストーリーなんですね
だからこの意見幾つかある場合は
データが足らないってことは明らかなんです
どちらが正しいかっていうことも言えないんです
例えば 宇宙に生命があるのかないかというね
わからないでしょうね
必ずしもあるんだよと
必ずもあるとは言えない
言えないしね で まあ地球と同じ条件の惑星はありえると
そういう惑星があり得るならば
水がある 惑星があるならば
生命が誕生する可能性があると
従って宇宙には生命があるというふうに結論付けるんです
だから あり得る あり得る
あり得る あり得る 従ってあるっていう理屈はちょっと理屈じゃないんですけど
あり得ると言った途端
五分五分ですからね  [背景音楽]で
その場合は地球以外の生命についてはデータが何一つもない
もし何とかの形で明らかにこれは地球外生命だということが知ったデータが入ったところでもう異論はないんですよ
それからはもう地球外の生命はいるというぐらいの結論には至れる
それで地球が丸いということは何の異論もない
意見はたった一つ 真理ということになってくるとそうでなければダメなんです
それまた変に間違ってますよ
どんな宗教も教えが形変わっても同じことをおっしゃってるんだと
それはもうあんまりにも頭が悪い連中いうことなんです
なぜかというと 一人の人間に世界にあるすべての宗教を勉強することは不可能なんです
あんまりにももう複雑で
もう頭がおかしくなるんです
それで一つの宗教を勉強すると
その連中は禁止するんですね
他の宗教を勉強することを
だからありえない そこでどんな宗教にも入らないで
真面目に勉強をまるっきりしない人が結論出すんです
いろんな宗教でいろんなことを言ってますけど
宗教はみんな同じことをおっしゃっているんだと
よく結論出すんですね
私はあんたたった一つの宗教の勉強していますか？と
それもやってない 一つの宗教を勉強してしてしまえば
私は結果知ってます その人の頭は全く悪くしちゃって
マインドコントロールされちゃって
他の宗教は勉強できない状態にする
だからありえない話なんです
すべての宗教は同じ道を教えるんだということは
理性ある人には言えないんです
でも結構言ってます で
真理は一つであるというのは
たった一個ということでもないんです
まあ複雑ですけどね まあ一応真理に至ったら結論というのは一つではあるんです
だからあるものについての真理がありますよ
それいろいろ 例えば今私の前にマイクロフォンがあります
このマイクロフォンの強度
硬さはどれぐらいですか？という我々疑問をつけたら
それの答えがあります
これ三次元の物体だから
進歩は何なのかという問題が出てくると答えがあります
しかし 強度の値と進歩の値はまるっきり違うでしょうに
違うんだけど 真理は真理なんです
このマイクロフォンの高さはどれぐらいですか？というと
10センチもありますし
5センチという人もいるし
20センチという人もいるし
そんなのはありえないでしょうに
高さははっきり決まってるんだから
重さははっきり決まってるんだから
強さははっきり決まってるんだから
真理はそういう意味で一つなんです
しかし マイクロフォンの強度と言えばと進歩と言えば違うんですね
これ感度 マイクロフォンだからね
感度はどれぐらいですか？とか
それは別々なもので 別な尺度で測るんです
だから知りたい情報によって変わりますが
結局真理は一つなんです
マイクロフォンの感度を知りたいというならば
もう感度を測る方法があるんです
それでどれぐらいですか？と言うんです
それと重さとまるっきり関係ないんです
重さで測れるものじゃないんです
それでマイクロフォンのはかりに入れて重さを量って量って
これがちょうどいい重さだから感度はいいんだよということはできないんです
言えませんね ありえないんです
そういうことで真理はたくさんです
色は何ですか？と言えば
まあ別で 重さはどこだと言えば
どれぐらいかと言えば
それはまた別で それで我々は知りたい真理ということなんですね
自分が何が知りたいのかと
この知りたいものには答えがあるんです
真理というのはそんなもんなんです
皆様方はブッダに聞く
私は金持ちになりたいと質問する
お釈迦様はどう答えると思いますかね
私は金持ちになりたいとお釈迦様に質問されたら知らないでしょう
お釈迦様は何のことなく金持ちになる方法を教えるんです
では君はこういう風にしなさいと
ブッダの答えはいつでも質問に答えるんです
相手が知りたい真理がありますからね
この間 スリランカの結構人気のあるお坊さんがさっさと来て
もう随分基本的な学校で子供たちに教える一つの経典なんですけど
これを教えてちょうだいと
だから私はもう向こうも向こうも一人前だから
そうじゃなくて あんたは色々疑問があったら質問出してみる
出せる質問が出せませんと
ただ教えてくださいと
困ったなということで
それで私はまあしょうがないということで
あらゆる釈道で説明してあげたんです
注釈してあげたんです
で まあ一人前の かなり国でも人気のあるお坊さんだからね
まあ教えるのは簡単ですけど
で なんで質問出せないで
ただ教えてくださいだけというのかというと
向こうが知りたい世界があるんですね
だから 自分の考え方で左右しないで
もう自由自在にこの経典はどのように解説できるものかと知りたかったんです
だから質問しない その場合は
それで私は喋りたい放題喋ればいいんです
相手が自分に理解できる範囲でもう理解して
理解できないものはそれも漏れるんですけどね
それもしっかり勉強する方法なんですよ
それで その中にあった一つのポイントなんです
その経典を持ってきたのもそういうわけで
このあの この在家の方々にした教えが特別に仏教にあるんだぞと言ってるんではないかと
それが正しいんですか？という質問もあったんですけど
基本的には私はこの人々はね
経典に名前を付けたり注釈したりする場合は
これは在家の戒律やとか何とかいうのはその人の自由であって
別にそれを気にする必要はないんだと
ブッダの教えは在家出家というふうに区別することはできないんだと
真理ですから しょうがないでしょうと
で 明らかにある教えはもう在家にはもう
できない部分もある それでこの経典になってくると
出家には関係ないことをいっぱい言っている
だから在家に限ってるんだぞと言っても構いませんということで
では読んでみましょうと言って
全部読んで説明していったんです
そちらにこの質問者も我々は在家で家族を持っている
だからこの世の中で結構豊かで贅沢に生きていたいんだと
しかし 死んでからも幸福になりたいんだと
地獄に落ちたくないんだと
だから質問がすごい単純で
この世の中ですごく豊かで幸せでいて
死んでからも天国にも行きたいんだと
教えてくださいと でお釈迦様の教えを教えてくださいってことじゃないんです
だからそこで相手がいて
相手が知りたい情報がある
普通の在家の人々として
最高な豊かさで 子供たちと家族と友達親戚とものすごくもう万々歳で大成功を収める
それでは物足らない それでもだからで死んだら地獄の道だったらもうもうちょっと割に合わないんだから
こちらで贅沢していたいんだが
いたいが 死んでからは天国にも行きたいんだと
だから普通女性が買い物に行ったら一番いいものをくださいと言うんです
値段は一番安い値段で売ってくださいと
もうそれかみ合わない条件なんですね
一番安い品物の値段で一番高い品物を売ってほしいということで
結構時間かかるんです
で まあそのような質問なんでお釈迦様出されたのは
お釈迦さん あんたなんたることを言うんでしょうかとか
そんな話じゃないんですよ
こんな贅沢に奢れて生活すると地獄に落ちるに決まってるんではないかとかね
そんな話ではなくて 質問に答える
そこでお釈迦様 本当の二
三行で教えてますよ この二
三行説明しながら 私はあのお坊さんに言ったんですよ
世界である経済学の基本的な間違いはお釈迦様ここで直してるんだと
商売するビジネスして生きている場合は
ビジネスが倒産するんですよ
どんなビジネスでも そちらに問題があるんだと
誰も分かってないんだと
お釈迦様たった一言葉でその問題を解決しているんだと
そこでその人に倒産ありえない
どんどん成長する商売をやる方法を教えているんです
でもそんなお釈迦様大胆なことを教えるんだという発見は誰もしないんだからしょうがないんですけど
そこで一応まず金の商売する方を教えて
それから次に得た収入をどうやって維持管理するのかというね
そこは説明して 次に維持管理だけじゃなくて
社会状況の中で生きていなくちゃいけないんですね
みんなと関係を持って
そこで素晴らしい人間として生きるセクションを教えて
で 最後に心清らかにする
そこをつなげて  四ステップで商売して収入を得る
収入を正しく管理する
人間関係を正しく保つ
心を清らかにする で 教えてこれでやってくださいと
ぴったしの答えですよ
それが違いますよと言える人間がいません
だからお釈迦様っていうのは
我々が出した質問に答える
あるボラモンが朝から晩まで怒っているんです
訳があると怒るんですよ
訳がないと怒るんです
どうしようもないんです
奥さんが朝喋ったら なんでお前の声
朝早く最初に聞かなくちゃいけないんですかと
と怒るんです  1日の最初の声はお前の声でもう 1日不幸になるんだよと
そこで奥さんがすごく気をつけて
次の日は黙っていると
なんて家の奥さんなのに
もう何も喋らない 黙っていると
もう不幸じゃないかと
それに怒るんです だから何やっても怒るんです
とにかく 本人がもうもう嫌になっちゃったんです
自分の性格には 怒って怒って怒って
何があっても怒って怒って
嫌になってお釈迦様のところに行って
もう嫌やと この人生は
怒りにもう狂ったような生き方をしているんだから
私を助けてくださいと
この怒りをなくす方法を教えてくださいと
その人にはその怒りを解除する方法
それを教えてあげる で
それにはいくつか方法があるわけじゃないんです
その人々をお釈迦様に教えられたら
その言葉はもう絶対的な言葉として守るしかないんです
もう真理ですから  2つの意見があるわけじゃないんです
そういうことで 仏教はたくさんあるのはそういうわけなんです
我々はたくさん質問したんだから
もうたくさん仏教はありますが
それでもあんまりたくさんではないんです
もっともっと人々は質問出したならば
すごいもう量の仏教になるはずでしたけど
もう結構修飾はしています
それでサッダンマンというのはとにかく真理
どんな真理かということはちょっと言いにくい
学校に行って地理学を勉強するならば
地理学のデータは真理でしょ
落ち着いて聞かないとわからないんですよ
落ち着いて勉強すると地理学は勉強できるんです
でもその中で地理学を勉強してたら何の役にも立たないんだから
別なことを勉強したいと思ったら別なこと真理になるんです
どちらにせよ だっても落ち着いていく条件は必要なんです
こちらで仏教が言う真理は
智慧を開発するために必要な真理
頭を完璧にするために必要な真理っていうのは 32種類に分けてます
37 全部精神的な心理学的な条件なんですね
37があります  37条件がありまして
それ完成すると智慧は完成すると
これは菩提分師と言いますからね
菩提というのは悟りを得るために揃わなくちゃいけない精神状態としてね
で そういうことは知ることできないんだと
時間はなくなりましたが
次の言葉に行きます パリップラワパサードス
パリップラワっていうのは浮いている状態
なんかもうタンポポみたいに
一箇所に止まっても また風が吹くとまたどこかへ行く
あるいは落ち葉 落ちる落ち葉みたいに
もうなかなか不安定で
どこに落ちるかわからない
パリップラワって英語ではフラクチュエーション
フラクチュエーションって何でしたっけ？フラクチュエート
揺らぎですね で パサードっていうのは信頼
信仰なんですが あの仏教でいう信仰というのは面白いんですよ
で 気に入っちゃうんですね
できるならば 例えば将棋やろうと思ったら
なんとなく自分がそれをわかってできそうな状態だったら
まだ勝ってもないんですけど
できそうだとめちゃくちゃ面白いんですよ
そうすると集中するんです
例えば 見たこともない材料を見ると料理する気持ちになりませんだけど
なんか自分がもうすごい元気のいいジャガイモやらね
もう新鮮そのすごいかっこいいピーマンやら色々玉ねぎとか見ると
なんとなく楽しくなっちゃうんです
これならこういう料理できるんだぞとかね
あの心に湧いてくる喜びなんです
信という信仰というのは
それでその仕事をするんです
例えばかっこいいノートと鉛筆とかボールペンがあると何か何か書きたくなるとかね
で 書きたくなったのは書けるんだっていうことなんです
それで歌でも一つ書こうかなと思って
それで考えて書く その信仰っていうのは
この恐怖心とつなげるものじゃなくて
喜びとつなげるものなんです
それはどういう喜びかというと
何かできそうみたいなというね
やれるぞという自信なんです
ですから この仏教は信仰はあまり大事に言ってないんですが
信仰は必要であると 人を信じることは
人か神か誰でもいいんですけど
しかし 信じる前にその人の資格があるかないかを調べなさいと言ってから
信仰といっても ただ単にいたずら
むやみに信じることじゃないんです
信仰 正しい信仰っていうのは
あ この人についていたら私にもできる
できるようになるという
自分も動くいくというあの
あの喜びなんです 大体この有名な学校なんか選ぶのはそういうわけなんです
この学校に入ったら 子供はなんとかうまくいけるぞという親の信仰なんですね
そこで子供もいい学校に入ったんだから
もう立派な人間になれるそうと思っちゃえば
もうなれるんです 何のこともない
単なる信仰です 信仰ですが
やっぱりそこで心を喜ばしてくれるんですよ
すごい有名な入りにくい
競争はすごい激しい学校に自分が入ったならば
入った子供もやったそうと
これではうまくいけそうと
勉強できそうという喜びがあるんです
その喜びがきっかけになって
場になって 人を成長してくれるんです
まあ全てもうもうもう誰でも入る
もう入学試験ももうただ形だけ
名前か番号書いただけで合格という学校に入っちゃうとそれがないんでしょうね
そういう入学試験もあるでしょ
番号書いたら呼ぶんです
で 合格します そういうことだ
学校に入っても入った生徒にはやったぞという
これならできるぞという信仰はないんです
最初からもう私はダメな人間で
もう誰でも入る学校には入りましたと
どうせもうそもそも元々ダメだという信仰ないんだから
結果としてもダメな人間になるんです
で そういう一番レベルが最低の学校に入っても
学校は学校じゃないんですかと
教える教育は同じじゃないんですかと
だったらやってやるんではないかと
自分で信仰を作れば もう学校の名前
看板関係なく頭が良くなります
我々弱いんだから看板探すんですよ
で 看板見てからその学校に入る
学校の看板は何の関係もないんですよ
しかし 人間は探す 小学校も中学も選ぶ時でも
高校選ぶ時でも 大学選ぶ時でも看板ですね
とにかく それはまんざら悪いという意味じゃないんですよ
だからかなり競争は激しいという
入りにくいんだというふうなところに入ったところで
本人が自信がついちゃって
それは仏教でいう信仰なんです
それで成長するんです
そちらでパリップラウパサーダっていうのは揺らいでいるんですね
この信仰は で 勉強できそう
やっぱりダメでしょうとかね
立派な有名な学校に入っても入ったんだから
私も合格したんだから大丈夫ですよと思ったとすぐそんなこと言っても
みんな私よりかなり手強い生徒たちじゃないんですかね
みんな軽々く合格しているんだから
私は回目でしょうとかね
それで友達に君は私は回目ですよと言った途端
こいつは回だけで入ってるんだから
私が回だ やっと回目合格したんだという感じでしょ
それで信仰あったりなかったりなんですよ
先生たちも生徒たちはみんな頭がいいんだだからね
親切に教えないでしょう
ビシビシビシビシ授業始めちゃうと
俺がついていけるかなとかね
いうことで信仰を失ったりする
逆に一流の先生たちがいるんだから大丈夫
もうすごいしっかり教えてくれるんではないかとかいうこと
また信仰があったりすると
そんな性格だったら いくら有名学校に入ったっても結果はになっちゃうんですね
だから私たちは何かできそうだなぁと思ってかかったら
その気持ちでいなくちゃいけないんですずっと
できそうだなと思ったら
もうできるんだという信頼でずっとやり遂げるということは必要なんで
そこで中途半端でこんなこと言ったってもう難しいんだこれはとかね
できそうもないんだとかね
いろいろ心が変わる 揺らぐんですね
信仰も揺らぐ だから信仰揺らぐことと
前言ったことは信仰揺らぐことじゃなくて
落ち着きがない だから落ち着きがあって
真理勉強しようと思ったら
やっぱり信仰が必要なんですよ
なぜならば長い道だから
完全に知るまで やっぱり難しい
やめたという途中でやめちゃうとダメなんです
だから 途中で諦めないで
明るい気持ちで喜びを感じながら
ここまでできた ここまでできた
ここまでできたと ここまでできたんだから
ここからまでできるんではないかと
次はこれにチャレンジするぞと
次にはこれにチャレンジするぞという感じで
いつでも前向きに信仰を持っていくんです
だからそれは宗教でいう信仰とはちょっと違う
これは心理学的な状況なんです
例えばお釈迦様を信仰するということは
お釈迦様は完全知者である
絶対間違ってでも嘘を教えたことはない
人間のことはもう完全に憐れんでいる
だから人間の幸福に至るもの以外一言葉を語っていない
それも絶対的です ブッダの場合
そこでお釈迦様は信じる
信じて もうとにかくおっしゃっている通りにやってもらう
酒を飲むのをやめなさいと言ったら
ずっと酒飲んだ人にとってはそれは厳しいんですよ
いつでもごちゃごちゃごちゃごちゃもうパチペチャペチャペチャ食べるなよと
で 頭はほとんどストップしているんですけど
口だけはストップないです
何か食べてる それでお釈迦様は口を止めて頭を浮かせと言うと
これはちょっときついんですよ
慣れてない人にとっては
でもお釈迦さんは悪いことをおっしゃっているわけじゃないんです
そこで信仰が働くんです
いや 私はお釈迦様が言うことやってるんだから立派だよと
あの小さな苦しみをもうものにしない
酒やめなさいと言われたら
すぐピタッとやめる それで友達にちょっといろいろ言われるわ
パーティーなんかに行ったら
まあちょっとどうしようかどうしようかという困っているところもあるわ
でも気にしない 私はお釈迦様の言ってる通りにやるんだから
こんなこいつらに何が言われたってね
気にするもんかと この連中
私の幸福願ってるんですかと
私の幸福は完璧に願っているのはお釈迦様ではないかと
酒洗いませんとお釈迦様には
という感じで この信仰を自分のガードというかガイドにして心を育てる道に持っていくんですね
だから仏法僧を信仰するというか
そういうことで良いことをする時の勇気に使うんです
誘惑に勝てる勇気に使うんです
あんた言うことは聞きませんよと
何ですか？と言ったら
私は仏法僧をいうことを聞いているんだから
なんでこの知らない仏教なんか知らない仏教かもしれませんだけど
あなたのこと知ってるんですから
あんたは人のことを愛する人でもないし
嫉妬深いし 別にあんた私が幸せになろうがならなかあんた関係ないでしょうし
あんたただ言うだけでしょうと
だからあなたのことは知っている
お釈迦様のことは知らないんだけど
お釈迦様は完全に生命のことを憐れんでいる
だからそちらの話聞きますという感じで道を定めるんです
だから信仰は否定できないんです
訂正するしかないんです
正しく信仰を抱く方法
だから迷信だけは絶対ダメ
信じるのは自分のことを心配する人を信じる
それだったらブッダ以外は誰もいない
絶対的な人というのは
母親も自分のことを心配はしますが
母親は全部知ってるわけないでしょうに
だからそこそこ信仰するんです
母親のことも父親のことも
そこそこなんですけど
それは失礼じゃないんですよ
例えば母親に聞いてもわかるんですかね
自分の子供の将来どうなればいいかどうかはわからないんですよ
幸せになってほしいという気持ちはあるんだけど
それ以上は何もわからない
だから母親は医者になれと強引に押しても
そこら辺は母親の気持ちも気持ちですが
自分が別なことを選んでもいいんです
なぜかというと 母親も知って言ってるわけじゃないんです
それで 俗世間の人々は適当にそれなりに信頼はしますが
この変わらない信仰になってくると
仏法僧で終わっちゃう
その３つしかないんです
それでこの信仰ということは喜びです
納得なんです できそうという自信なんです
この自信 喜び 納得というものは揺らぐんだったら
もうものにはなりませんね
そこで心はしっかりしてほしいんです
そういう状態条件だったら
パンナーナパリプーラって知恵というものは完成しませんよと
落ち着きがない それだったら真理する方法もない
勉強してもしても頭に入りません
それだけじゃなくて 勉強するために必要なこの納得
喜び 自信 それも揺らいでいる
だったら そういう人間は知恵は完成しないんだぞと
お釈迦様もおっしゃっているんです
それで我々は知恵を完成しなくちゃいけない
知恵を完成しなくちゃいけないんですから
知恵を完成するためにこの条件を捨てるんです
この悪い条件をね それでそれをもう長い時間かけて説明しましたけど
これ誰にでもわかる簡単なことなんで
落ち着きなさいよと でなきゃ頭よくならないんだ
何勉強したって頭に入らないんだよ
ということでね 頭に勉強は入ったっても
勉強するものを理解しながら喜ばないとうまくいかないですよ
最終卒業までは これはその条件を言ってるだけ
それが俗世間にも当てはまるし
悟りの世界にも当てはまります
だから同じ方法で方法論です
同じ方法論で俗世間でも成功を収めます
ブッダの世界で悟りも収めます
なぜかというと 方法はそれしかないんです
真理です 落ち着かなくても勉強できるっていうことはありえないんです
落ち着かなくても 精神不安定であっても
いい仕事をできますよと
ありえないんです まるっきり嫌で嫌で勉強できるっていうことはありえないんです
全くも嫌な仕事 仕事も嫌であるし
同僚も嫌でしょうし 顔も見たくないし
この会社か工場の建物を見るだけでも
もうもうもうもう吐いたいぐらい気持ち悪いと
それだったらその人いい仕事できると思いますかね
いくら能力あってもできない
喜び感じると 会社のところで看板見えると
会社に入る道路見ると
うちの会社だ 俺の会社だというね
それなんとなくすごくワイワイ湧いてくる喜びが
そこで仕事できるんです
学校でも学校の看板見えると
もう文言見えてくると楽しくて
私の学校やとかね そういうふうな
この それが信仰の世界
喜び感じる 学校でも学校も喜んで
この廊下やら各教室やら
もうこれはこれで これはこれと喜び感じると
この雰囲気 それで人間に対してもね
あれは教育の先生だ これ音楽の担当だとかね
そういうその環境の中で喜び感じるとうまくいきますよということで
そんなのはもう事実ですから
もうしょうがないんです
[終始背景音楽]